you might not be able to sit down for
this one a Georgia charter school is
planning to bring back the use of
paddles on students who break the rules
this year the Georgia school for
innovation and the classics sent home
consent forms to parents requesting
permission to spank their children with
wooden boards the form says after their
third offense students will be taken
behind closed doors and received quote
no more than three licks Wow the school
superintendent told our Augusta
affiliate WR DW that a third of parents
who returned the forms gave consent
there was a time where corporal
punishment was kind of the norm in
school and you didn't have the problems
that you have it's just one more tool
that we have in our disciplinary toolbox
parents can opt out of the controversial
policy instead their child could face
suspension for up to five days for
misbehaving Georgia is one of 20 states
we're paddling in schools is legal
that's interesting to know that in 20
states it's legal I'm glad we didn't go
to school in Georgia I'm opting out I
don't think somebody should be allowed
to physically physically punish your
child parents parents - you know you
know it's is much harder to sit down and
have a conversation and talk to them
about what they did wrong before you or
you use that or anybody physically
touching my child I don't want to do
that